There have been several points over a dozen
seasons of Storage Wars during which bidders
have genuinely hit pay dirt.
If you're wondering which abandoned lockers
held the largest treasure troves, here are
some of the biggest payouts in Storage Wars
history.
If you search for the biggest recorded find
on the show, chances are one storage unit
is going to show up every time.
The unit was purchased way back in Season
3 by none other than Darrell Sheets, the gutsy
gambler whose presence has been a staple on
the show over the years.
Sheets spent $3,600 on a locker that looked
interesting, but not particularly special.
Imagine his surprise when he discovered that
it was home to a whole slew of paintings by
Frank Gutierrez.
"Jackpot, baby."
The proud new owner was floored to find out
that the whole collection was worth upwards
of $300,000.
"Hold on just a minute…
300 thousand dollars?!"
Over the course of the show, the Gambler has
found other ways to make bank besides dealing
in rare art.
In this case, it came in the form of a toy
and comic book collection that he purchased
back in Season 5 which he called…
"The Holy Grail of toys."
The locker contained an endless supply of
collectible dolls and toys, along with an
absolutely massive collection of comics: We're
talking 3,000 books.
The count kept rising as Sheets tallied up
the mountain of collectibles, finally settling
on a total that topped $60,000.
Husband and wife team Rene and Casey picked
up a locker during Season 6 that paid astronomical
dividends.
As the couple began unloading the treasures,
they discovered an endless procession of high-value
pieces that ranged from a beautiful grandfather
clock in mint condition to a set of Baroque
by Wallace collectible silver that was easily
worth at least two grand, along with an oil
canvas painting that came with its own self-valuing
paperwork stating it was worth $8,000!
By the time all was said and done, the couple
was practically standing in a museum, and
the locker was valued at $50,000 minimum.
While he wasn't particularly remembered for
his huge paydays, Barry Weiss, known as "The
Collector," was a staple of the show during
its early seasons.
"Put that in your pipe and smoke it."
The Collector came through in a big way during
Season 2, when he showed up late to an auction
and quickly bought what appeared to be a worthless
locker with a couch and a few odds and ends,
all for a seemingly overpriced $1,525.
It turned out that in a small box tucked away
in the back, there was a wooden sculpture
of a person's head with real inset dentures
and glass eyes, along with a window in the
back of its head that revealed an entire scene
taking place inside the brain.
The rather odd piece turned out to be a bit
of a collectors item and was valued at $6,000.
"But the problem is…"
"'Cause you're not letting it go.
Typical Barry."
Midway through Season 3 of the spin off show
Storage Wars: Texas, Mary, the woman known
as "The Junkster," got into a disagreement
with her partner, Jenny, over an antique candlemaker.
Jenny wanted to sell it for 50 bucks, but
Mary wasn't about to accept that kind of petty
cash.
She took it to a candle shop where the seller
appraised the unsuspecting little unit at
an impressive $1,400 at the least.
While it isn't a shocker as far as the price
tag goes, the piece's estimated price still
increased nearly thirty-fold in value during
its valuation, which made it one of the more
unexpectedly valuable treasures to ever air.
"Today, this bull is a cash cow."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.